the
opinion of a stronger player than us who
is joining us in the studio we have ray
robson with an incredible start two and
a half out of three uh despite starting
with two of those three games being with
black uh ray how does it feel
oh yeah it feels pretty good i
i mean
i don't know today's game was pretty
complicated i'm not really sure what to
think about it um i think it was it
started off quite slow with the joko
piano but after that it just exploded
yeah i mean i think the italian isn't
really i mean it's kind of a slow line
it's very complicated not anymore these
days there's tons of theory so i
actually played an i think a novelty
um
in the opening with d5
uh let me get to that point
about the way back here
yeah if i'm in this position yeah
because already knight d7 is a little
bit
unusual and normally the idea would be
to play with f5 if you're going to move
the knight to d7 but i have to ask you
one question
how do you keep all the italians
straight
how do you not confuse one with the
other yeah i'm not sure i mean i get
confused also i guess
let's say if you're black i guess you
just try to choose like one sort of
setup for a particular game and just
look at all the lines
in that variation if you're white
you you probably need to remember a lot
more because black can do so many
different things so
uh it's a difficult opening
difficult opening to prepare um
but yeah i mean what he did was
interesting take 693
all very natural i played f5 and then he
went d4
and after e4 i spent a lot of time
because i thought e4 he was going to
play c4 uh which is like very sharp
um so i spent
i used up all my time advantage thinking
about this and then a bishop f7 right
you spent all your time yeah yeah
talking bishop f7 d5 um
one idea was knight e5 knight takes e5
knight takes bishop c5
bishop c5 here so he traps my rook but i
should have some play and i can come to
d3 queen can come to g5 with some
threats it's very complicated that's
what i was thinking about but instead he
just played knight h2 immediately and so
i felt really dumb because i would never
have i would have moved instantly if i
knew he was going to play knight h2
um but yeah this position is still very
unclear like it's
i can play f4 which looks very tempting
um looks like i have a big attack but
after he just moves the bishop back
i don't know how to continue yeah bishop
not sure which one but one of the
squares
then e4 is a weekend now um because yeah
because my f pawn moves so c4 is an idea
always and his knight now has a square
on g4 in the future
um so it's not clear so instead i kind
of played much more slowly and then the
game was um
yeah just a lot of maneuvering but it
felt like he was putting some practical
pressure on me i didn't think my
position was like bad but
um he was putting some practical
pressure and then much later in the game
um maybe around move
30. uh he made a
move like queen
or was it queen b6 which was very
very unexpected
this is a very complicated game but yeah
oh queen b6 is here yeah i mean he just
moved his queen all the way away from
like his king my last move was rookie 8
so it's clear i have some ideas to maybe
play e3 and finally get some sort of
direct play going
instead of queen b6 i was kind of
concerned about d5
c takes d5 and now very interesting move
c5 maybe
if i don't take then he has a pass pawn
so if i take bishop takes f6 gf6 queen
f6
rookie 7 looks the most logical then it
could be eight
rookie eight rook takes bishop takes
queen takes f5 it's equal material you
would think it's um completely fine for
black but somehow is knights activating
i have some weaknesses and there's some
concrete lines like let's say queen d6
knight g4 king g7 looks like
everything's secure but he has queen h5
he hits h6 and my knight's pin to the
bishop
and if queen f4 then d5 hangs it's very
unfortunate i
i couldn't find like a easy defense here
so i wasn't sure what i was going to do
if he if he went for that um instead
queen b6 we were both now low on time
and yeah then i just went for the attack
and
i'm not sure what if we played the best
moves but in general it seemed like the
game completely shifted in my direction
at this this point queen d8 and now yeah
bishop e8 maybe he kind of
underestimated this
he doesn't really have any threats and
i'm threatening the bishop and the
knight with the rook
and seems like
yeah i'm just winning material by force
here yeah this is collapsing and of
course after yeah this is not gonna hold
the two pieces are too powerful
oh that nice you it seems like you
outplayed your opponent in that
complication
wasn't unable to keep pace
yeah
i can show one line at the end very end
of the game the last move
um that he made so here um
so i'm threatening the rook i'm
threatening knight e4 actually to block
his queen from defending g2 so he has to
hope for some miracle perpetual ideas so
rookie seven i thought was the best
try and then f94 maybe he can sack i
mean it probably doesn't work rook g7
but he can try it so instead i i thought
the most precise was knight
six or knight three to d5 right six to
d5 knight six to d5 and now for g7
king g7 queen d7 uh king f6
queen check somewhere king f7 and then i
block on e7 with the knight and
everything's defended so i thought that
was a clean win
great back to back victories with the
black pieces the second one how do you
feel uh
at this point and who do you have
tomorrow
yeah so my previous game i was just
white so it wasn't
back to back with black but yeah my next
game i think i'm white against jeffrey
white again jeffrey that's a big matchup
wish you good luck and we'll see you in
the next round thanks